(applaudissements)
- Le sourire du vainqueur.
C'était en 1979, Robert Mugabe
venait de signer la déclaration
d'indépendance du nouveau
Zimbabwe, après avoir combattu
et renversé le régime raciste
et violent de la Rhodésie
britannique. Il tendra la main
à ses anciens bourreaux,
mais sera sans merci pour
ses adversaires politiques.
Les escadrons de la mort sèment
la terreur, ce qui lui permet
de garder le pouvoir pendant
37 ans, malgré les désillusions.
(coup de feu)
Robert Mugabe avait hérité
d'un des pays les plus
développés de l'Afrique,
avec une agriculture moderne.
Il ajoute à cela un vaste réseau
d'écoles publiques et des soins
de santé gratuits.
Mais les violences politiques
font fuir les investisseurs.
Au début des années 2000,
pour relancer sa popularité,
il plonge le pays dans une
réforme agraire dévastatrice.
(cris)
Les fermiers blancs sont chassés
de leurs fermes, parfois
violement et les employés noirs
sont congédiés. Le pays est
privé de son expertise agricole.
Les terres sont données
à des amis de pouvoir qui,
souvent, ne connaissent rien
à l'agriculture. L'économie
du pays s'effondre, le Zimbabwe
doit abandonner sa monnaie,
les écoles et les hôpitaux
manquent de tout. Le choléra
et le sida, nié par Mugabe,
font des milliers de morts.
D'autres Zimbabwéens
lui rendent hommage.
"Il a joué un rôle crucial
dans la guerre de libération,
il a donné du pouvoir
et une voix aux Noirs.
Il nous a donné le courage
de nous tenir debout".
"C'était une icône, dit-il,
une légende africaine, sa seule
erreur fut de s'accrocher
au pouvoir trop longtemps".
Mugabe a encore voulu
prolonger son règne, en 2017,
en tentant d'imposer sa femme
à la présidence.
Ce fût une fois de trop.
L'armée l'a chassé du pouvoir,
tout en lui permettant de finir
ses jours en homme libre.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.